After 177 episodes, "The Walking Dead" has
finally come to a conclusion.
Well, sort of.
Are zombies evolving?
Will Michonne ever end up finding Rick?
Fans definitely have questions about plenty
of loose ends, and we're here to explore the
most pressing of them.
When "The Walking Dead" premiered on Halloween
of 2010, we were introduced to Rick Grimes,
who woke up from a coma in the middle of a
zombie apocalypse.
The fast-paced horror of that episode gave
way to years of post-apocalyptic social drama,
spending practically no time exploring what
happened to cause the outbreak.
There have been plenty of hints as to what
initially caused the outbreak.
For instance, an episode of "Tales of the
Walking Dead" set in the future notes that
scientists eventually learn that the virus
was created in a French laboratory.
Likewise, we've seen something of the catastrophic
early days of the infestation through the
underrated spin-off "The Walking Dead: World
Beyond" as several children experienced some
of their earliest memories of losing their
parents to the sudden influx of undead.
Yet, there are still plenty of questions around
what exactly caused the outbreak, and it's
hard to say if the franchise is ever going
to address them.
In many ways, the beauty of "The Walking Dead"
is that we don't actually need to know what
happened — but we can't help but be curious.
Rick's farewell to "The Walking Dead" series
in the 9th season is epic.
Despite hallucinating and being near death,
he manages to divert a horde of undead away
from his friends and family.
When an explosion takes out a mass of the
walkers, it seems certain that Rick has met
his demise, as he is nowhere to be found afterward.
Enter Jadis, who we meet in the 7th season
as the leader of the Scavengers.
Her time with the group shows her to be an
enigmatic and puzzling character, and she
ultimately leaves to join the militaristic
CRM.
When we see her again in "The Walking Dead:
World Beyond," she makes veiled references
that could easily prove she knows more about
Rick's whereabouts than anyone.
"And I created a ticket to get into the Civic
Republic.
I gave the CRM something very valuable."
Jadis saves Rick with the help of a helicopter,
and then the series jumps six years into the
future, where Michonne writes diary entries
to her presumably late husband.
However, in the 10th season, Michonne finds
Rick's boots and an old iPhone with her and
Judith's faces carved onto its surface, and
she realizes that Rick is very likely still
alive, leading her to head off to find him.
In the finale, it seems more likely than ever
that we're eventually going to figure out
what Rick has been up to — but currently
it's still a mystery.
Since Rick has always been the face of the
series, it goes without saying that his fate
is possibly the most pressing question fans
have.
"The Walking Dead" is well-known for introducing
epic big bads, from the Governor to Negan
to Alpha and the Whisperers.
For the 11th season, the major enemy is the
seemingly non-violent Pamela Milton, who "disappears"
countless Commonwealth citizens that prove
problematic to her.
Aiding her is her hateful and spoiled son
Sebastian as well as Lance Hornsby, a politician
who constantly lies to get people on his side
only to revoke his support in crucial moments
to colonize the outlying communities in some
sort of manifest destiny plan that we may
never see the full extent of.
Sebastian and Lance both meet satisfying deaths,
and Pamela gets captured after her evil actions
are made known to the citizens of The Commonwealth,
but maybe that's not the last we'll see of Pamela.
Though there are plenty of surprises with
the undead in the early seasons of the show,
over time, they become more of a static background
threat that could occasionally leap forward
and take loved ones if you aren't constantly
alert.
Living humans remain the most unpredictable
threat in the post-apocalypse, while the undead
stick to traveling in herds and feeding.
This final season changes that, and the danger
of the hordes grows exponentially.
Through several episodes, different characters
notice odd developments with the zombies,
surprised to find them in places that they
shouldn't have been able to go, casually dropping
hints to viewers that the undead might be
evolving into a greater threat than ever before.
When a group takes refuge in an abandoned
township, they see the extent of this as a
walker not only scales a wall but opens a
door simply by using the handle.
"When did the dead use frickin door knobs?"
Previously, zombies could only bust through
barriers, but using deductive skills was not
a thing they could pull off.
During the attack on the Commonwealth, we
see more of them coming over fences and walls,
demonstrating again that the undead are getting
smarter.
From the beginning of "The Walking Dead" up
to his death in the 8th season, Carl Grimes
played a major role as his father Rick's right-hand
man.
When Rick teetered on the edge, nearly giving
in to his dark side, Carl was able to call
him back, pointing out that his own belief
system should prevent him from crossing those lines.
In that way, the next generation has always
played a huge role in the morality of the franchise.
With Rick, Michonne, and Carl all gone, Judith
becomes a major character over the last few seasons.
Showing the same determination and heroism
as her parents, Judith is able to defend the
other children but also takes part in major
events while inspiring the adults around her
to keep their eyes on the prize during conflicts.
"What we're doing could help everyone.
Not just us but maybe everybody everywhere."
Though we almost lose her in the finale due
to a gunshot wound, Judith survives, leading
us to wonder where she and the other children
will go from here.
We have no idea where Rick has been over the
last several years, though the hints dropped
in the finale suggest he's probably in need
of some help.
We see him decked out in a CRM jacket, stuck
at a riverbank, dismayed by the number of
undead stuck in the mud and snapping at his
feet.
He throws his backpack on a boat to keep it
from being confiscated, leaving a trail for
Michonne to find, as a voice through a loudspeaker
warns him,
"There is no escape for the living."
If there is one thing we have seen time and
again in this series, it's Michonne pulling
off superhuman feats of bravery.
As Rick surrenders to his captors, images
are intercut with Michonne, who has never
stopped searching for him.
Alone and surrounded by the horde, she continues
on, hacking away at the undead with her trusty
blade and riding an armored horse into battle
in search of her love.
"Rick and Michonne" will no doubt see a reunion
between the two, even if only through memories
and flashbacks, but it's not guaranteed that
Michonne and Rick will make it to safety.
With Richonne fans across the globe holding
their breaths, we're hoping to get some answers
in 2023.
This season spends a lot of time delving into
the animosity between long-time fan favorite
Maggie Greene and the villain turned antihero
Negan, who murdered her husband Glenn during
his time as the ruthless leader of the Saviors.
Understandably, Maggie is still upset about
this, despite Negan's presence as a helpful
member of the Alexandria community.
"Killing you, it's always on my mind."
Now married and soon to be a father, Negan
is wracked with guilt over what he's done
and attempts to sacrifice himself to a firing
squad to save the others.
But, to Negan's shock, he gets rescued by
Ezekiel and other members of the community
stepping up around him and Annie.
After that, he apologizes to Maggie for the
first time, telling her that it took all of
the horrors they've been through for him to
fully understand what he had taken from her.
"I am so sorry for what I took from you and
what I took from your son."
Though she tells him she can't forgive him,
she admits that she's ready to move forward,
which will open the door for their pending
spin-off, "Dead City."
However, we still don't know how they end
up in New York.
After Rick and Michonne leave the series,
Daryl makes a seamless transition into a central
role, where he spends more time with the community,
helps to raise Judith, and even works for
Mercer as one of the Commonwealth's soldiers.
His dedication to the community has been clear
since the early days and he's always been
a true friend to both Rick and Michonne during
their time as leaders.
More so than almost anyone else, he and Carol
have remained vital characters, surprising
us countless times by jumping in and saving
the day.
The finale sees Daryl spending most of his
time trying to keep Judith alive as the horde
overruns the streets of the Commonwealth.
In her delirious state upon waking up, Judith
admits to Daryl that Michonne is on a quest
to find Rick.
Surprised to hear that his friends are still
alive, he doesn't make any immediate moves
until we cut to the One Year Later segment
that ends the series.
Daryl says a touching goodbye to Carol while
preparing to head off on his own journey.
Where is he going?
We're not sure, but we're guessing that Rick
and Michonne are at the end of that path.
The ending of "The Walking Dead" was pretty
great overall, but the series couldn't fully
manage to grant adequate screen time to its
countless amazing characters.
Though arcs for many characters wrapped up
or at least put them on the path to their
next adventure, plenty of others struggled
to find a resolution.
The Commonwealth is now the home of many recurring
characters, from sisters Connie and Kelly
to King Ezekiel himself, and these are all
people we're dying to see more of.
Since Magna's group first appeared in the
9th season, they've counterbalanced the loss
of major cast members by repeatedly proving
their survival skills are unmatched.
Eugene and Max fought hard for their relative
sense of peace, but are we ever going to see
what Eugene is like as a dad?
"That there is a video game worth a pre-order."
Over the years, "The Walking Dead" has been
surprisingly adept at tying up its loose ends
and viewers seldom lose sight of a major character
or plot thread without some sort of explanation.
However, the people behind the show are only
human, so there are still a handful of questions
left over from the earlier seasons that we've
never quite resolved.
For instance, way back in the 4th season,
Grady Memorial Hospital was shown to be overrun
by villainous monsters masquerading as healthcare
officials, but after Beth Greene's death,
we never hear about it again.
Even though Daryl killed the head of the organization,
we've spent years wondering what happened
to everyone else.
Another question that has fans scratching
their heads is, "What has the Civic Republic
been up to?"
We're pretty sure they have to be aware of
major townships like the Commonwealth.
We've seen their "ends justify the means"
approach up close and personal through the
"The Walking Dead: World Beyond," but their
status as ruthless protectors of humanity
has always been a bit vague.
We're dying to hear more.
With Hilltop destroyed and both Alexandria
and Oceanside having been invaded by Commonwealth
soldiers, it's harder than ever to understand
what's going on in the outlying communities.
And their fates are even more jeopardized
now that so many of their best and brightest
members are all heading off in different directions.
The benevolent King Ezekiel is unlikely to
ever turn his back on the other communities,
particularly the ones he once found a home
in.
Aaron was uniquely committed to Alexandria,
which means he very well might return to it
as a leader and usher in a new era.
The full status of Oceanside and whether it
will make a comeback is unknown, but we're
looking forward to finding out soon.